the US government's response to the
coronavirus has been nothing less than
catastrophic including weak delayed and
incompetent actions by its two main
public health agencies the Centers for
Disease Control and Prevention and the
Food and Drug Administration Alex
Tabarrok a professor of economics at
George Mason University and one of the
cofounders of the popular blog and
online University marginal revolution is
an outspoken critic of the government's
actions including the FDA's refusal to
allow for home testing of the
coronavirus Reason spoke with him about
official responses to pass pandemics
what countries are doing things right
and how the government can get a better
handle on stopping the spread of
coronavirus yeah I would say that the
response of both the CDC and the Food
and Drug Administration there has been a
failure of historic proportions I've
always been you know skeptical of the
FDA but this failure is so extreme that
it's really remarkable I mean even I'm
surprised that it's been so bad alright
here's the basic issue look China gave
us a window of opportunity by locking
down Wuhan by having immense controls by
shutting down their economy they took
these tremendous actions weeks and weeks
months before we did and that should
have sent up a signal flare to everybody
in the world take this seriously I mean
I as an economist not an epidemiologist
not a microbiologist
I looked at what China was doing to
their economy and I knew this has got to
be taken seriously because the Chinese
aren't stupid they're not going to be
throwing away trillions of dollars and
entirely locking down their economy for
something which is quote you know like
the flu I mean this is see a very
serious issue and the whole job of the
CDC the whole reason we have the CDC is
precisely to prepare for pandemics like
this and the CDC utterly failed they
first tried to create their own test
instead of adopting the already
working w-h-o test that delayed testing
then the FDA compounded that error of
the CDC by not allowing private labs and
but not allowing state labs to do their
own testing so this was an absolute
disaster which combined with everything
else the government wasn't doing has
really delayed our response tremendously
what is the role of testing it in kind
of combating and containing the corona
virus well look this virus is extremely
infectious that is each person if inward
innate in the ordinary business of life
will typically transmit it to three or
four other people and so you have a
cumulative process like that right that
within a couple of days it goes from one
person to three people and then from
those three people each one of them will
generate it to three other people so you
got nine when they fee and so forth and
so forth so these exponential processes
grow tremendously quickly and that's why
what looks like nothing today you know
suddenly is a huge issue and is
overwhelming hospitals now the other way
of putting that is that if you can test
and trace you test that first person you
trace them to the three people who me
transmitted the virus to okay then you
can stop it maybe if you test quickly
and you contact trace then you can stop
it in its tracks but if you don't do
that then very very quickly it is
completely out of control and is
everywhere in the United States why why
did the FDA and I guess also the CDC why
did they you know not wave once you know
once the corona virus showed up here why
didn't they waive their standard
operating procedure and say okay we need
to get more tests in place or we need to
open up the process to include more
people yeah I mean this is just typical
FDA procedure and like any bureaucracy
they are slow too
I do think they should have of course
acted much much sooner but the FDA was
doing what they always do they were
following the rules and the regulations
which have accumulated over many many
years okay and those regulations are
just there they're slow they're
cumbersome they're bureaucratic this is
normal standard operating procedure now
Trump of course is pretty awful I think
I think you know Trump's handling of the
crisis has been terrible but in no way
can this all be blamed upon Trump Oh a
lot of this was baked into the
completely legal completely normal
procedures of the FDA the FDA has at
least as of today and we're talking on
Tuesday the 24th they banned or they
they put a stop to at home testing for
coronavirus why is that problematic yeah
it's ridiculous because you know the FDA
has been forced we firstly were forced
to allow the private labs pests which
finally they did and that has increased
the number of tests and they allowed the
states to do their tests and so that has
increased but yet still their attitude
is to clamp down so a number of
companies a month ago started to produce
and in just the last week started to
sell at home test kits okay now these at
home test kits you're only collecting
the sample at home there's a swab up
your nose right and then it's sent off
to a registered and certified lab so all
of the science is done in a certified
lab and the FDA said today or yesterday
that we're not going to allow these at
home tests and I think that's
problematic for several reasons
now it may very well be true we don't
know but it may very well be true that
an at-home test is less accurate
when a nurse does the test you have to
stick to swab pretty far up your nose as
what I've been told
okay now there's a couple of things one
some of that can be caught at the lab so
then you can do is test the second time
second did we really want nurses doing
all of these tests at this point in time
where nurses are in short supply I think
it's actually a good thing that some
people are doing the tests at home
second yes it is true that you might get
you know a false negative okay which
means that you think you don't have it
and you actually do have it now clearly
that's not good okay but it does mean
that as your symptoms get worse well
then you can go to medical care right in
again it's not perfect you may take some
actions which you otherwise wouldn't
write but at this point in time we
really need many more tests and we need
to draw on the American ingenuity and
free enterprise to express this in a
decentralized fashion as fast and as
quick as possible
are there any countries that so far I
mean you mentioned China China what you
know is an authoritarian regime they you
know what I mean I've seen videos of
people being nailed into their
apartments after testing positive for
cron and things like that is that the
model that we should be following or are
there other countries that have
contained the virus in a way that is
more kind of comports more accords more
with a kind of liberal democracy right
yeah
China took very strong actions I don't
necessarily think those are the actions
we should have taken you know three
weeks ago we may now be forced to do
what China did we may not have much of a
choice but some of the other things
which have been done South Korea has
been very very good testing and tracing
and so what you want to do there is you
want to test as soon as you find a
positive test you find out every one
that person has met with or been with in
the last two weeks and you go and you
test them okay
and in this way you kind of clamp down
and they have despite having a very fast
increase in the number of cases they've
bent the curve in other countries we
still don't know you know what exactly
is is going on everywhere but Japan is
an interesting case Japan
wearing masks is a quite common people
even in normal times will you know walk
around on the subway with a mask and
that appears to have allowed Japan at
least so far we don't know but it
appears to have allowed Japan to do very
well in this crisis and here we got I
think again bad information at the
beginning people were told oh the masks
don't do any good right just preserve
them for you know the hospital workers
and of course the people in the
hospitals they do need masks and the our
first priority but it does appear the
masks work right in that spy because the
the mode of infection seems to be when
you vaporize when you COFF you sneeze
whatever if you're infected that goes
out and it comes to contact with other
people so you're keeping it in yourself
and other people are not getting it it
works both ways
yes you are keeping it in and also
you're not breathing indirectly if
someone sneeze or something like that
and it just prevents you from touching
your mouth nose yeah it's because the
watermen is picked up on hard surfaces
yeah the very mechanical kind of
prevention technique you know one of the
other things that you have you've
criticized at marginal universe marginal
revolution excuse me is the defense
productions act this has gotten you know
this is one of those laws that's been on
the books for it for a long time but
never really gets invoked can you
describe what it is and why you think
it's a kind of false Savior in this
situation yeah so the defense production
act is is sort of what you see in the
movies right is the trucks are all
leaving they're all run
away from the front and the army comes
in and says we're gonna requisition
these vehicles to get our troops you
know where where they're needed and in
that kind of sense I think it's fine and
if we needed to build tanks you know and
you know the it was you know literally
people were invading and I think it
would be fine but the main issues that
we're dealing with right now are ones
where the consumers want masks the
consumers want hand sanitizers consumers
and the medical professionals they want
ventilators so all of the market signals
are all working in this direction that
we want them to work and for this idea
that the government can simply come in
and go to a factory and say you know
you're making cars but now we want you
to make ventilators it just doesn't
doesn't make a lot of sense for two
reasons one the government doesn't
necessarily know what actually are the
best substitutes in terms of production
for the ventilator and what are the what
are the real machines that you need to
make the ventilators the government
doesn't also know the secondary
consequences that is if you take some
factory and you turn it from producing
you know cars or trucks or something and
now it's producing ventilators
well maybe you needed those trucks to
frame you lenses I don't know
right but the government doesn't know
those secondary consequences all of that
is much better handled by the price
system we let the prices rise we let
entrepreneurs figure out hey maybe
there's a better way of producing these
things maybe we can produce them
maybe there's you know animal models
which can be used you know maybe it's
not like the truck manufacturers which
have the actual technology to produce
ventilators but it's accordion makers
maybe the accordion makers really I have
run the right technology do you have to
worry I can you know in the early days
of you know when the coronavirus really
hit and I guess you know thinking late
why not there were runs on things like
toilet paper
obviously hand sanitizer is in short
supply do you feel like the productive
capacity of the United States is up to
kind of providing what we need or do we
need you know are we going to have
persistent shortages no no no they're
the productive capacity is there no
question so already the shelves in most
places are either filled or refilling
we're not going to prevent eyelet paper
okay don't worry about that
we're not even going to run that the
hand sanitizer that's being taken care
of that'll be filling the shelves again
quite quite quickly we can do all of
that stuff really quite well now we're
already
also ramping up on masks and things like
that but again one of the problems with
the Trump administration and with the
the trade war with China is that China
now actually is a very good place for us
to go buy masks because they've got a
handle on the disease there they produce
millions of them every single day okay
ventilators as well they don't need
quite as many as they were producing so
actually the thing to do would be to get
on the phone say can we get fill up a
plane with these things and that would
help with some of our emergencies so
rather than blame the Chinese you know
we can talk about that some other time
let's get that book we'll worry about
that when the disaster is over it's very
obvious that this disease attacks all
human beings right it does not respect
borders and so we need to work together
and the Chinese they took the first hit
they now have a lot of productive
capacity which we would like to buy from
them and we should be thinking about
doing that what you know one of the
other things that you've written about
at marginal revolution online people can
find it you know if they google it
you've talked about you know some people
now are saying that we've been too blunt
in locking down all people base guy I'm
talking to from new
York City you're in the Washington DC
area these are two cities that have had
a real you know substantial lockdown
non-essential workers are supposed to
stay home and either you know just get
unemployed or work from home you are not
some people are starting to say you know
what we need to do this is a disease
that strikes mostly older people with
underlying health conditions we should
be quarantined them but we should be
letting younger healthier people go back
to work and kind of restart the economy
what is your critique of that it's too
early to do that there are two problems
with segregating the elderly the first
is that look even though the probability
of dying is lower if you're young
there's still an awful lot of young
people okay a lot of people less than 65
years of age including myself whose
probability is pretty damned mine okay
given given the background given
background rest and there's a lot of
them so it still means potentially
hundreds of thousands of excess deaths
among young people moreover it's going
to be very hard to keep the death rate
down if the hospitals become overwhelmed
that is what Italy faced what Italy is
facing right now even when you can treat
people in a normal situation and they
might recover when you have gone when
you lack that in ventilators when you
lack beds when you lack physicians when
you lack nurses you don't have enough of
them okay then the death rate is going
to go way up so that's the first problem
it would mean a lot of young people
dying the second problem is this idea
that we can segregate and isolate the
elderly or those most at risk that makes
sense
when most people don't have and don't
get the virus but if you're talking
about segregating and then letting
everybody else go back to work those
other people are gonna get the virus and
they're going to give it to their
grandparents and they're going to give
it to their
you know coworkers and other people the
in the same apartment building and so
forth so it's actually segregating the
elderly it really only works when not
that many people get the disease so I
don't so I don't think so I think it
said so I think the idea is sort of self
contradictory in in two ways one it will
kill too many young people and two it
actually won't work segregating the
elderly actually won't work that well
what is your sense from a kind of
economic point of view though how long
can we you know how long can we sustain
an economy where we're you know people
are talking about having a massive
shrink shrinkage of the economy you know
over the next couple of months how long
can we go on with a workforce that is
essentially idled yeah there's no
question that it's going to be a very
sharp very sharp decrease in gross
domestic product and this can be very
painful
unemployment is gonna be high now what I
do think is that if we can get the
number of tests up and we can start
testing and tracing which means that you
find somebody who is positive and you
trace every one and they've they've come
into contact with and test them then we
can start to do two things one is people
who are negative we can start allowing
more of them to meet with one another
okay you're right so you put on negative
you know we may have to have badges okay
and those people can start to go back to
work second there's a second type of
test which is not whether you have the
virus but whether you had the virus and
that is that test works by looking to
see whether you have antibodies whether
you have the whether you the immune
system has developed some of these
antibodies to attack the virus and if
you have the antibodies that suggest
that you've had some immunity so the
people
you have been infected and you have
recovered they're also going to be great
workers because you know you're not
worried about working with them because
they have some immunity so for both of
these reasons testing and identifying
then we can start getting people back to
work but to do that first we need to
first we need to flatten the curve as
Dee said what do you think how long will
that take you know under kind of current
circumstances or current practices what
are we looking at for before we get to a
point where we start opening things up
again yeah so it really depends upon how
quickly we can ramp up the number of
tests a lot of tests are being developed
the duccini coming online pretty quickly
but it's still far less than I would
like when we have a lot more tests and
when we've got New York and San
Francisco and Seattle when we have those
cities under control then I think we can
start to do some of these things maybe
in a few weeks that's what I would hope
I think we can do things like the
following we shouldn't really be having
not for very long just sort of dividing
work into essential and non-essential
right instead what we should be doing is
saying things like you can go back to
work if everybody in your work can wear
a mask and doesn't interact with the
public right so there's lots of you know
firms where they're you know in a
factory or you know they're building
something you have the workers there
they're not interacting with the public
you know every worker on an assembly
line can wear a mask many of them would
be wearing masks anyway right so those
workers should be able to go back that
is instead of just saying essential
versus non-essential we should say like
just as we do with food anybody can open
a restaurant so long as they follow the
following health conditions and so
anybody should be able to go back to
work so long as the workplace and
follow the following kind of conditions
you wrote recently about a study of the
1957 Asian flu outbreak in the United
States which killed between seventy
thousand to a hundred thousand Americans
what with what did you find when you
looked at this because reading your
write-up of the work on it it I mean
it's staggering really that this
happened you know with in relative
memory and nobody seems to really think
about it at all
that's right it's very puzzling because
we had in 57 and early fifty-eight a
pandemic quite similar to what we're
having now it was not quite as
infectious and the fatality rate for
those who got it was not as high so it's
not as dangerous wasn't as dangerous but
as you say you're talking like a hundred
thousand people I mean that obviously in
the late at least I wouldn't have known
World War two but that's double what
died in the Korean War
absolu years before absolutely and there
was a big recession also a very sharp
recession so growth fell by like ten
percent in that first yes I think you
notice that that it produced a right
around them was the worst quarter post
World War two on record but then you
said that when you looked at people who
were talking about that period none of
them even mentioned like economist
analysts don't even mention this exactly
so I'm I was a little puzzled at this
because from today's per sec perspective
it seems pretty obvious that the flu
would have sent a lot of people home
from work and was worldwide and this
recession was worldwide but nobody at
the time kind of thought that it was
causing the recession so I'm actually
not sure I actually think this is a
puzzle for economists to look at was was
the was the recession caused by the
pandemic or was it just coincidental
well certainly we did not do all the
things we're doing now you know yeah I
mean is that because uh you know I don't
want to say life was cheaper than but it
so just I mean it was it that the the
concept of medical interventions you
know in a kind of mass way we're not as
developed or people were willing you
know again it's hard to think about this
but you know whether it's the 1918
Spanish flu epidemic
you know the depression World War two
etc there was just seem to be a higher
tolerance for adverse effects I mean
that our you know events that are just
terrible yeah I think that's right I
mean I think you're absolutely right I
mean this was a generation or
generations which had gone through Great
Depression World War two Korean War and
all that kind of stuff and you know I
think they were more hardened to it plus
of course they had less choice you know
thank God for the internet right the
Internet and the American internet right
has held up incredibly well so this is
something I think we all ought to be
amazingly proud of the American Internet
is is conveying much much more traffic
and it has done so seamlessly I mean
look at us I mean we are having a
conversation across you know you're in
you're in LA right Bob in New York
you're in New York right and yet we have
full video and it has not failed us yet
so the American Internet has been
incredible you know one of the one of
the things that a number of people are
observing you and your you're part of
this you're building out a kind of
cloud-based world marginal revolution
University has a ton of online courses
you teach online I guess both through
marginal revolution and you also do you
do teaching distance learning for George
Mason is what I do I did so I have to
admit that the crisis has I'm less
affected by many people since I was
already teaching online so my class
actually has continued just as if
nothing had happened so I'm more
embarrassed to to admit that
because it is easy or it is easier for
someone like myself who can work from
home to say that we should you know lock
down or keep the lock down for longer
and you know I'm not I'm probably not
looking at unemployment so I understand
all of that but ultimately the economy
is about people right and there's no
point having high GDP per capita if per
capita is really low
okay that's not the way we want high GDP
per capita yeah what do you think is the
hardest thing I mean and obviously I
mean academics I think in many ways
journalists are many journalists
certainly in my own experience I've been
working from home either full-time or
part-time for almost 25 years at this
point like you this is there are real
cost to it and it and this is the slow
squeeze psychologically I think it's
gonna become more and more apparent on
people but day to day it's not that big
a lifestyle change for me what do you
think is the hardest thing for regular
kind of workers in the meatspace economy
you know where they're face to face
every day what is the hardest thing to
kind of get by or to kind of to adjust
to in in the in the current moment well
I'm not sure about that exact question
but I will say this I think one of the
things which is so difficult about this
is we're dealing with exponential
processes and it's very very difficult
to understand exponential processes so I
think a lot of people are looking around
and and say well why are we doing this
and the reason we're doing this is
because it doubles every three days
right and so I think it's very hard to
understand or hard to convey to people
the counterfactual what would the world
look like if we did not lock down and I
think that's one of the reason why we
were so slow because it's just hard to
believe that something can grow that
quickly and unfortunately we all sort of
seem to need examples and even China was
not enough of an example Italy
apparently provide enough people always
say well that's different
China is different or Italy is different
or whatever well again
in here yeah I mean it and it does seem
that we may end up somewhere in between
the two I mean Italy even for Europe and
I guess Spain is also experiencing
something similar these are you know
despite being part of Western Europe or
you know and and and familiar to people
Italy has always been a poor country it
is you know so it may be that whatever
is going on there is not going to be the
same here do you think when will we know
if the current course of actions are
effective enough what at what point can
we say ok we at least know what's
working and what isn't
yeah how long will that take so anything
we do today won't show up for another
two weeks
so that's why you know we've really only
been in this you know ten days or so so
I'm expecting you know later this week
and of you know so next week hopefully
we'll bend the curve you know and get
control of Seattle and San Francisco and
New York New York is now looking like
our Lombardi I hope that's not true
but I think if we can get control in
those in those cities then we'll know
we're doing the right thing
final question you know as a good
libertarian I mean you've been you've
been writing from a broadly libertarian
perspective your entire professional
life you know early on in this and of
course because people you know don't
want to deal with actual problems they
immediately go for cheap shot so there
was a flurry of articles about how there
are no libertarians and a pandemic etc
you know does this shake the way that
you think about the size and scope of
government or the way that it should
function or or do you feel like this is
actually validating I mean it's some of
the criticisms you are talking about the
FDA you know where do you come out of
this from an ideological perspective so
let me start with the FDA because as
you've known as I've been long been a
critic of the FDA saying that they're
too risk-averse and you know right now
lots of people are agreeing with me
right because lots of people are finding
themselves oh I'm at risk but here's the
thing when you had a deadly disease it
was just a bit as big an emergency you
know a year
go as everyone is feeling today so look
put yourself in the other guys shoes
okay people have to be able to do that
so well if I had cancer if I had you
know pancreatic cancer if I had you know
some heart disease I would like the
right to try I would like to have you
know medicines come out faster right and
so I think this does very much support
me on the FDA and we have to think about
you know everything people are saying
now that applied you know five years ago
okay there's nothing new there's nothing
new there the FDA has always been too
risk-averse now more generally on sort
of libertarianism generally I think it's
quite clear that the strongest part of
our response has come from the private
sector the private sector you know
whether it be Amazon or Walmart or
McDonald's okay they are really keeping
this country together and the
decentralized approach letting the
states letting private labs come out
with their own tests that has been very
very much supportive this
command-and-control
I think has failed utterly failed and a
lot of people can see that now now
you've sorry so let me say give me one
more and that's a negative one and that
is that look you know I want the small
government okay I want it much smaller
than it is now but I damn well want to
get what I pay for right I mean we are
paying a huge chunk of our income to the
government and one of the things which I
think even I as a libertarian think the
government should do is you know handle
pandemics and things of that nature
right and they're failing so they're
failing to provide the public goods
you know the whole economic reason for
government is to provide public goods
and they're failing on that so I do
think that pure competency you know
really matters and here you know the
Trump administration I think is
especially incompetent
it's not that you know other governments
lots of governments are incompetent
there I think especially incompetent
I don't want to you know totally go have
trumped arrangements there it's not all
Trump small but just pure competency I
think really matters and there's
something about the the US which does
seem you know when we talked earlier
about how difficult it is to build a
subway line you know how difficult it is
again anything approved like we could
not build the Hoover Dam today right you
know the environmental review alone so
would take years so the there is
something which we do seem to become a
you know a sclerotic Society and I think
pure competency and ability to get
things done that also matters so that's
the sense in which I guess I'm observing
a little bit less libertarian or
something like that you know when but I
want the governor to act I wanted to
tamp I'll act well and competently and
that's something which I'm not seeing
alright we're gonna leave it there Alex
Tabarrok
of George Mason University and marginal
revolution thanks for talking happy to
be here all the satiric next time yeah
this has been the recent interview with
Nicholas B thanks for listening please
subscribe to us at reason com
you